[Music]
if only the air quality were better in
london rossamond kissy deborah's
daughter might still be alive today
[Music]
ella was almost seven when she suddenly
became very ill
my late daughter is ella roberta and she
had one of the worst cases of asthma
ever recorded in this country so it
started in october you know signs of a
cold a cough that sounded like whooping
cough and her first admission or her
first
coma or seizure was in december it was
linked to air pollution
and through my research i found out that
air pollution it affects millions
worldwide
until she fell ill ella was a completely
healthy child and very sporty she loved
swimming and football and also played
several instruments the asthma changed
everything
my life was rushing to work and then
always having my phone near me in case
her school rang to say her lungs had
collapsed
ella suffered for two years before dying
of an asthma attack her mother became an
activist
with the help of doctors and liars she
was able to prove that her daughter's
asthma was particularly bad on days when
the air pollution was extremely high
i wanted it officially recognized i
thought for all she suffered she
deserved that 28 months of her
suffocating in her mucus basically
she deserved to have that moment
i don't want other children in this
country to go through
what my late daughter went through
london has a problem most of the city
exceeds the world health organization's
air pollution limits many of the famous
black cabs run on diesel which is
particularly bad for air quality
hundreds of londoners end up in the
emergency room each year because of
toxic air the mayor sadiq khan has
introduced countermeasures and stiff
charges for drivers with older more
polluting cars but it's not enough
we've shown the way with some
world-leading policies from the world's
first ultra-emission zone to reckon
number of electric buses increasing
hugely the number of charging points and
i'm hoping for a green recovery as we
come out this pandemic
the capital urgently needs clean air
particularly for the children saint
mary's school is on one of the worst
polluted roads in southern london
parents have decided to take matters
into their own hands
ella's death was one of the driving
factors
it just sort of confirmed our fears you
know we we knew everybody knows you know
everybody knows it's bad and everybody
knows it's bad for children you know
they're growing up
the lungs needs to develop you know i
remember taking my son to school one day
and got into the playground
and the noise when this from the street
was just deafening you know
these cars going by a hundred thousand
cars every day
the parents crowdfunded almost 100 000
pounds to buy air purifiers for the
classrooms as well as 12 000 plants for
the schoolyard to act as natural air
filters
before the children weren't allowed to
play outside for more than 15 minutes
i think it's a good thing because it
might actually stop the air pollution
coming into the school they smell nice
and
and that they give us air
because our school is right next to a
really busy road
so it helps us a lot
but rosamond kizzy deborah thinks that
more is needed
laws are what really matter and
children's rights definitely matter and
it is their right to breathe clean air
and all government should make that i
don't care how hard it is by the way
i really don't care how hard it is they
can achieve that
rosamund kissy deborah knows that air
pollution can be deadly
she will continue to fight in the name
of her daughter so long as there are
other children whose lives are at risk
because of poor air quality